awesome Brett I'm sorry go ahead yeah so
I'm a college senior right now I'm
trying to figure out my path and I'm
just wondering if you knew at any point
in your life like what your path would
be and like how much you stuck to it
when you got started not just way back
when but also like when you started
vaynermedia and all that as well so what
banal media I didn't know like the first
two years I was half involved the agent
was really running the show right and
then it got to a place where i saw the
opportunity momentum and i adjusted so i
like i like halftime adjustments using a
sports analogy i'm not i probably the
coach that's not as good game planning
you know Monday through Saturday and
then Sunday comes on the coach that
we're down 27 two three and a half time
I'm like do this do this through this
and boom we went 30 to 27 overtime right
I'm more of that kind of businessman so
I react a lot but as a top-level thing
being a businessman and not worrying
about my grades honing my craft and
selling when I was a kid and a teenager
thinking about the psychology of why
people buy things those are things that
I've been doing since I was eight nine
seven four you know and so uh I've
always been that right I always knew
that I was gonna be an entrepreneur even
when that word wasn't sexy yeah i mean i
hear you i'm actually at the last day of
my internship i'm a mcglothlin struggle
through that all summer so I'm really
trying to find the next step and
definitely things around here helped out
a lot so what do you live Buffalo New
York nice are you build spam ah yes
Sargon kinda like this kid um ok I
understand home town right now listen I
understand I said I understand let's
move on break um so what do you think
you want to do I mean I spent the last
couple months before here in San
Francisco working at a tiny little
startup shout out to the Ranga vacation
rentals but um I've dug the
entrepreneurship and the whole vibe out
there so the goal is to get back there
when I graduate well good man good luck
listen I like you so much of its
serendipity that we met this way I want
you send me an email to Gary at
vaynermedia com I know every startup in
San Francisco I'll get you at that all
right thank you man well one main reason
for one main reason because anybody
who's selling winter gloves in the
summer gets my respect yeah I know you
boss it's cold up here
I hear you respect man oh man all right
so Brett's gonna get me an email we're
gonna get him a job because that's what
we're doing here